today on training versus traditional
we'll be making two different versions
of the same dish for this specific
episode we are going to be making
chocolate chip cookies arguably the
greatest treat that's ever existed it is
never not a good time to have a
chocolate chip cookie you're gonna be
making a trendy chocolate chip cookie
whatever that means
stay tuned good luck you're up first
right yes i am all right should i go now
yes you can go now okay fair enough
so we're actually making chocolate chip
cookie shot glasses or just chocolate
chip cookie cups i got the idea from
chef dominique ansel who actually
created this recipe i think my role in
this show is to just be boring but good
that's what i'm going to try and aim for
with these chocolate chip cookies and
we're going to try and hit a really nice
pun intended
sweet spot not too chewy not too cakey
not too
crispy i have my ingredients out i have
my butter eggs flour brown sugar white
sugar vanilla and a lot of chocolate so
i'd say in terms of ingredients there's
nothing out of the ordinary baking is a
little trickier for me because you have
to be a little more precise with your
ingredients to me i always think of
baking as more of a science but it's
gonna be pretty simple we're gonna have
dry ingredients and wet ingredients into
the oven uh cookie time okay let's do
this this butter has been sitting at
room temperature
just diced it up
i'm just gonna smoosh this a little bit
oh yeah that's what you want you see
that now that's satisfying now that this
is super soft we're gonna add in the
white sugar and then we have the brown
sugar also tossing that in
now we're just gonna cream this together
it would have been a lot easier if i was
doing this on a stand mixer sometimes
when you work harder the cookie also
tastes better sweat and tears everyone
you have my word that at some point
during this recipe i will get flour all
over my tropical shirt so we're doing
two and a quarter cup of flour to start
so i'm gonna be a nice boy and measure
out
oh
not my floral shirt but very close the
flower was warning me
do not mess around
okay it's looking a little bit fluffier
that's a good sign
i think that uh that's a well
incorporated
now that the butter and sugar is done
we're gonna add in the eggs i'm gonna
take that out
boom
two eggs cup number two
oh boy all right so that's two and a
quarter
enough goofing off baking soda scares me
because i only associate baking soda
with the science project that everyone
made where you pour it into a volcano
and the idea of putting that into a
recipe always
it doesn't sit well with me i'm gonna
add a splash of vanilla to it
just a little bit
give that a
gentle whisk
[Music]
and then we're just gonna put this in
there
i think salt we're gonna take a little
bit of a creative liberty
and that's
we'll do more than three so now that we
have our wet ingredients pretty much
ready to go we're just gonna add the dry
ingredients so i have flour here baking
soda and a bit of salt
baking soda
just a generous sprinkle
we're going to take it up a notch it's
going to get a little more exciting
we're going to involve some heavy
machinery basically what we're doing is
we're going to put butter sugar and eggs
into this stand mixer and
swirl it all together so now that we
have
the dry ingredients
we're going to sift it
we just want to stir it enough for it to
combine with the wet ingredients if you
mix it too much it's actually going to
become too tough there's nothing wrong
with being a tough cookie but i like
mine softer and chewier we are going to
go
very aggressive with the butter butter
and salt where is this gonna go wrong
it's not those are two things that make
everything better stick and a half we're
gonna heat it up a little bit in the
microwave when you do that it's
important to let the butter then cool
back down a little bit you don't want
scrambled egg cookies that's looking
pretty good i know there's still some
flour on the surface here but we still
have to toss in the chocolate so we have
a stick and a half of butter that's
going into our stand mixer i am so bad
at measuring do you see this two-thirds
of a cup
of white granulated sugar fractions are
tough guys oh boy a little spillage
these are gonna be sweet i'm actually
gonna cut up these chocolate chunks
they're both just semi-sweet here we go
there's really no reason why you
shouldn't use chocolate chips i just
like it when it's like chocolate chunks
or chocolate shavings she's more fun
give it a whirl
hey
she's uh
she's a wild one here are our chocolate
pieces
i'm gonna toss that right in
boom chocolate explosion
hello we found a smaller piece so now
the robotic uprising has been quelled
that looks like it's supposed to i'll
talk into the microphone so you can hear
me over the machine now we're gonna let
this run for a couple minutes you want
the butter and sugar to get nice and
creamy i love how this looks
it's almost turned the like part of the
dough into chocolate which is great
because
more chocolate i love that i'm actually
going to let it rest for an hour let it
chill in the fridge then we're going to
take it out roll it out and then we can
take it from there now we're gonna put
our eggs in one egg
give it a whisk second egg
a little of this goes a long way god
vanilla smells so good i am a big
vanilla boy i've already made it farther
in this recipe than i thought i would it
looks like cookie dough so
these are going to turn into cookies
here we go rest of the dry
ingredients so this has been chilling in
the fridge for an hour so the idea is to
mold this
a little bit
and then
roll it out into a sheet so then we can
cut out rectangular pieces which will
then put the pieces into this mold
supposed to roll this out into like
one and a half inch thickness i'm using
every single
fiber of my being
and muscle
just cut this open
it's a little easier to work with set
that aside
so i don't want my cookie cups to be too
thick but i don't want them to be too
thin either so they're actually like
pretty big cookie pieces if you're just
looking at this last but not least
the
i think i do this every episode whatever
whatever my most crucial tool slash
ingredient is i display it like a fine
bottle of wine semi-sweet
morsels i hate the word morsels it makes
it sound like i'm an old witch dump
all
all feels like so much and then we're
not even gonna turn on the mixer we're
just gonna like combine okay so now i
have our six pieces i'm going to go
ahead and
put it in the mold
i actually think i'm gonna form little
balls to put on the
end
and then squishing them down like that
should i just fold it in i'm just gonna
put it in you guys didn't do this right
but it's okay it's okay we see a lot of
extra bits right now extra cookie dough
we can always just trim that off
we got this sort of do that that's sort
of what our first one looks like
i love cookie dough so much it's like
it's almost as good as cookie and this
is going to be
a pretty good indication of where we're
going to end up
here's to salmonella
[Music]
oh
i'm not like proud of myself it's butter
sugar
and chocolate this kind of feels like
when you're playing with play-doh
you know you're just shaping it into
whatever you want to do with it
now we just have these little molds
that we're actually going to push into
this cookie dough
um so that it can keep its shape
slide that in
last one gently hammering this in
boom we're gonna pop this in the oven
now hopefully when we pull it out it's
actually gonna look like
cups i don't know how
i think these cookies should be pretty
big we're gonna
oh god this
i think that looks okay right that's
gonna be two is that too much i don't
want to take this out of the oven and
it's like one sheet cookie
the cookie shots are out they don't look
exactly identical but
you can see that they are cup shapes
i've never done this before so
i'm just glad that it looks like
a cup shape
[Music]
i'm pretty pleased with how these look
if you asked me to draw a picture of a
chocolate chip cookie this is pretty
close i'm just going to coat the insides
of chocolate because
again extra chocolate is always great
but also
it helps the milk from kind of soaking
too much into the cookie and making it
overly soggy
[Music]
three two one
whoa
uh that looks awesome thank you thank
you
i'm assuming
that looks good our judge today is the
cookie master alvin he has been doing a
lot and a lot of videos on cookies so
there's really no better person than to
critique does it say cookie master on
his linkedin page hello hello hello
welcome what do we have here welcome to
the cookie dome this is really
interesting this is a chocolate covered
chocolate chip cookie shot glass with
vanilla milk because that's what you
have vanilla milk yeah
didn't explain that but yes there is
manila in here i had to this is i'm just
trying to do what the og person did
that's what chef dominic are you
comforting me already i'm very excited
to eat your cookie crisps it's fine it's
okay this is a chocolate chip cookie and
that's all i have to say all right here
we go starting in traditional land
like a very solid chop soup
i like that noise that's a good noise
and chewy i like the salt did you put
salt on it i did put salt on it high
five there we go yeah
it's gonna give you bonus points i have
this one it's a great solid cookie i'm
gonna try the trendy one now because it
looks really cool
oh that's fun nice wow so it's like
you can drink your milk but then you can
eat the glass too yes trendy all right
here we go
oh i smell the vanilla
mmm
oh it's so fun
[Music]
are you gonna take a shot when you get
up we don't get points for fun right but
you gotta you gotta um and this is fun i
maxed out it mm-hmm so yeah i'm sweating
this is so cool i have my decision so
from a flavor point of view
i think both of yours are great
out of five points give you a four
and out of five points i also give you a
four okay so they're both different i
think they're really cool from a
presentation point of view yours is like
you know when you come home you're
comforting your mom says to play down
you're like yes thanks mom i give you
also give you a four from your point of
view i think this is a cool trendy way
to present a cookie you're gonna get a
five so
my favorite i think the winner will be
the trendy cookie as someone who loves
cookies as much as anybody else i think
the texture the presentation vanilla
milk just knocked it out of the park
you did
you did it
i had regular men congratulations thank
you thank you for the winner and i'm
gonna go eat some more cookies
cheers
to a cookie battle
the vanilla milk so this episode is done
trendy takes this battle let us know in
the comments which type of food we
should pit against each other next and
uh see you guys next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you